and so i asked our teacher after this
whole exercise you know how do you
actually go about changing the world
like tactically speaking what are ways
to embody that message
and he told me ben one of the best ways
to change the world is to be an
entrepreneur
[Music]
ben kaznoka thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders i am so
thankful to have you here thank you for
being so generous with your time
thanks for having me michael it's a it's
a pleasure to have you we have
way too much to talk about i want to
just run forward
and considering everything that you've
done which is
incredible i'd love to hear about
village global i'd love to hear about
your work with uh with reid hoffman and
the two new york times bestsellers that
you wrote and
the different insights that you've
gained into helping
young entrepreneurs on their journey the
majority of the audience for the show is
young entrepreneurs like myself just
starting their journey
and i think that going back and reliving
some of these lessons that you
so thoughtfully highlight in in a lot of
your writing and that would just be
incredible so ben how about you take me
down
memory lane just walk me through some of
the really cool things that you've
gotten to take a part of
and we'll touch on some lessons here and
there from there and and i'll of course
interrupt
when i'm especially curious well when i
was 12 years old i
i took a class in school that was a
computer repair class
and so we learned how to fix and repair
macintosh computers
as an elective course at my school and
it was
designed of course to allow the school
to use us as child labor to repair all
the school computers when they broke
but i learned a lot about how to fix
computers in a really helpful class
and at the end of the semester we had a
final exam
but the final exam was very different
than any other exam i've taken the
teacher announced
that all we would have to do to get an a
plus in the exam is memorize and recite
a poem
back to him perfectly and if we could do
that successfully he would give us an a
plus in the class so the exam would have
nothing to do with all the material we
had studied
in the class all we would have to do is
recite a poem
and so 24 hours before the class he
distributes the poem and it actually
turns out
not to be a literary poem but rather the
text
uh transcription of apple computers
think different television advertisement
which ran in the late 1980s early 1990s
if you haven't seen the ad you can go on
youtube and search for apple computer
think different
and you can see the ad for yourself but
i was forced to memorize that ad
when i was 12 years old and recite it
back to him perfectly
and uh maybe i'll share it with you now
just for folks who don't know how it
goes
it's short the advertisement says here's
to the crazy ones
the misfits the rebels the round pegs
and the square holes
the ones who see things differently
they're not fond of rules
and they have no respect for the status
quo you can quote them disagree with
them
or vilify them but about the only thing
you can't do
is ignore them because they change
things
and they push the human race forward and
while somebody see them as the crazy
ones we see genius
because the people who are crazy enough
to think they can change the world
are the ones who do and so
at a really young age i was reciting
this message back to him
yeah it was it was life-changing and um
and so i asked our teacher after this
whole exercise you know how do you
actually go about changing the world
like tactically speaking what are ways
to embody that message
and he told me ben one of the best ways
to change the world is to be an
entrepreneur
is to see opportunity where other people
see challenge
to not just complain about problems in
the world but try to solve those
problems
and he said the next time you have a you
experience frustration in your life
ask yourself whether you could solve
that frustration for you and everyone
else who has that frustration and maybe
make some money while doing it
and you know up until that point in my
life i had really
not thought of myself as an entrepreneur
i didn't know much about
entrepreneurship
but he really inspired me to think
to apply that lens to the world to see
problem as opportunity
and so i started my first company when i
was 14 years old and i've never looked
back
i seeing every problems an opportunity i
i love that
i i've been thinking that i i can't i
recall
when i was in the idf and i was leading
a team there and
you know we were constantly faced with
problems and especially in a very
bureaucratic area
you know a lot of the times these
problems surrounded the lack of finding
funding and the lack of
our ability to get new talent coming in
we had what we had and a lot of times we
kept saying michael we have a problem
and i kept thinking you know we have
we have an opportunity for a solution
and it's and and i just love that that
embodiment and mindset so walk me
through some of the other experiences
that you've had and how how have you
used that mindset to
to get excited about these problems that
you're facing
well the first bias that i had about the
mindset was that it was a silicon valley
only
idea i was living in growing up in san
francisco actually at the time i was the
and and so as i learned more about
entrepreneurship i i assumed
that what entrepreneurship meant was
starting a technology business in
silicon valley because that's
what everything that's what everyone
else was doing around me and it wasn't
until i really started traveling
and i left the us for the first time and
and
and traveled around meeting with
different people who had been who i'd
met online who had been following some
of my writing
that i realized that entrepreneurship
was actually global
that there are people all around the
world without mindset
and there are people creating all
different types of businesses all around
the world
you didn't need to be in san francisco
you actually also didn't need to be
starting a tech business there are lots
of different types of businesses to
start
and a lot of problems to solve in the
world and so
a really formative experience for me
after the mac
after my teacher forced me to memorize
the apple advertisement
was leaving america for the first time
when i was
maybe 18 years old and spending
four or five months in asia and europe
and
latin america and some in the middle
east and just meeting all these
different people who were inspiring me
with their own entrepreneurial energy
and that really taught me that
entrepreneurship is a global idea
and that it's a life idea more than a
business one it's a mindset that you
apply to your life
and to any industry you don't just have
to be starting an internet company
i just love that obviously you know
coming from israel my grandparents
came on the boats into a kibbutz and
that whole
entrepreneurial journey there they're
telling me like michael you know you
think you're an entrepreneur
you go to silicon valley with all your
vc friends and you
come starts no the real entrepreneurship
story is how this world is formed and
how we built railroads and how we
invented
you know agriculture in the middle of
the desert i mean these are the real and
so i i couldn't agree more and
talk to me a little bit about village
global because it's a phenomenal
phenomenal idea
it's not just another venture capital
fund you're having you're building this
incredible community of
global thinkers and global leaders uh
probably if i if i just start
reciting the names the jaws are going to
drop with people that are involved
and i have some great friends that are
part of this network tell me a little
bit about what you've built and what was
the motivation
behind building this 100 million venture
capital fund
yeah a few years ago my partners and i
founded village global to be
an entirely new sort of venture capital
firm
and we believed that the nature of
entrepreneurship was changing
and so we needed to build a venture
platform that would
change with it that would adapt to this
new world of entrepreneurship in the new
world of work
some of the ways that entrepreneurship
have changed include this global point
that we've been talking about which is
their great talent all around the world
uh it's cheaper and easier to start a
company than ever before
and increasingly software is
transforming all different types of
industries
and so it's a much more diverse set of
businesses today that vcs ought to
invest in rather than just traditional
software companies and so we built
village
with the idea of being a network-driven
venture firm that could invest around
the world
in all different types of i.t enabled
businesses
one of the things that makes village
unique is we've we believe that today's
young entrepreneurs
derive a great deal of inspiration from
their iconic heroes in the industry
people like mark zuckerberg people like
bill gates
jeff bezos and other folks like that and
so
we spent a long time raising our fund
from those people so those people
are the investors in village and then we
take their personal capital
and we in turn invested in the smartest
entrepreneurs that we can find so as to
sort of bridge the generations between
today's young entrepreneurs
and the luminaries who back village so
you know just to just to iterate your
this this you know this notion that
you're taking people like mark
zuckerberg j
bezos bill gates and the likes literally
investing their personal funds into and
venture capital fund
that whose mission it is to invest
globally
in i.t solutions that are really
breaking breakthrough
and and the smartest people how do you
go about fulfilling that mission first
of all it sounds like
it's a lot of responsibility it sounds
like a very scary responsibility to take
but i'm sure that it's incredibly
exciting but how do you actually go
ahead and deploy
that strategy and find those best people
around the world
we have a unique uh network model
for discovering the best talent around
the world so
most venture capital firms historically
have
operated where there's a handful of
general partners
who sit in an office usually in menlo
park california
or some other ecosystems tel aviv
different places around the world where
there are a lot of vcs
but the the partners really act as if
they are masters of the universe
as if they know all the people who
matter and they expect founders to
parade into their office and pitch their
business
but we have a different approach we we
leverage a network
of founders themselves angel investors
professors ecosystem leaders and we
empower
those people with our capital to go back
their smartest friends
and so it's a bit more of a
decentralized effort
to source and select the smartest
founders we can
and by using a network we're able to
find
really amazing entrepreneurs and hidden
and undiscovered places
well what do you get most excited about
because you're not
you're coming from a very
entrepreneurial background you've built
several companies your companies have
have made a huge impact back then and i
believe that some of the companies that
you've built
their technology is still being deployed
today one of which are used by hundreds
of local governments
so you're you've made a huge impact as
an entrepreneur yourself and now you're
making a huge impact as a venture
capital
investor what really makes you excited
about what you're doing
i think the thing that's really exciting
about our work is
being the first to believe in a founder
so we are often at village we're often
investing in pre-seed and seed stage
rounds
or formation stage rounds where we're
we're the first person to commit to
the first firm to commit to a founder
and so we really feel like we are
increasing the total entrepreneurship in
the world
there's a lot of capital that will pile
into late stage venture rounds where
they're already you know stripe for
example apparently is raised in a new
round of financing at 100 billion
evaluation that's awesome and stripes
had a huge impact but
it's more fulfilling for me to think
that we could be the first to invest in
stripe rather than
at the 2 million evaluation rather than
the 100 billion evaluation
because that's that's what it means to
bad underdogs that's what it means to
take risk
that's what it means to believe when
others do not
and i think there's something very
satisfying about having that sort of
contrarian
view and then seeing all these other
investors follow us
at later stages 100 i took a fascinating
class with
ann from floodgate at stanford venture
capital class and one of the things that
we talked about was the different
investment stages i i have the privilege
of doing due diligence in the fund
called j ventures very early stage and
one of the key differences that i was
always taught was that if you're
investing early stage
your due diligence is mainly about the
people it's about their backgrounds
about their personality and their
perseverance their due diligence on
later stages is
there's a lot also about the
spreadsheets about the finances about
your believing in the business model
moving forward so so i i can definitely
see the excitement
that you bring towards this ben take me
back a little bit to your
entrepreneurial journey
uh obviously you're doing incredible
stuff now with villager global but
that's just
you know the sliver about of of your
humongous experience
talk to me about the different ventures
that you've formed and the two books
that you've written with a reid hoffman
sure well i i uh you know rolling back
the clock to that
class that i took where i memorized the
apple advertisement and then the global
trip i took that opened my
eyes to global entrepreneurship you know
i spent several years
um founding and running an enterprise
software company
that sold crm software to local
governments
uh and i really enjoyed that experience
and that business continues today to
serve
um a whole bunch of customers in in the
u.s
um i took a few years
break from entrepreneurship and focused
on writing
and those are the books you mentioned so
i co-authored a book called the startup
of you which is a career strategy guide
on how to apply entrepreneurial insights
to your own life
and then i co-authored a book called the
alliance which is about how
companies can attract entrepreneurial
talent into their organizations and new
times bestsellers but that's irrelevant
of course
well that we were really lucky that both
books found a
an engaged audience and both topics are
really interesting i think
um and i learned a lot you know writing
forces you to clarify your thinking
um and and so to really flesh out
my views and to get to know my co-author
reid hoffman who started linkedin and
both of those books
was a really tremendous privilege and um
and so i've been going back and forth in
my life between writing and
entrepreneurship
uh these days i'm 100 focused on village
global and entrepreneurship and venture
capital
but i suspect in the future i'll go back
to writing books at some point and
hopefully go back and forth because
you can have a different sort of impact
writing books you know for me my drug of
choice is impact so entrepreneurship's
certainly one way
but you can also influence the way
people think and uh
books and articles uh are a way of doing
that for me
right all this back and forth going from
being an entrepreneur to being a writer
spending time at the linkedin and
greylock offices
venture capital suspecting going back
talk to me about this whole mindset of
moving around and experiencing and
really mastering and harnessing these
different skill sets
as a lifelong entrepreneur i think some
of us
live lives that are unplanned
and serendipitous and involve lots of
zigging and zagging
and that's certainly been my life uh
i've never had a
grand master plan uh every year
brings its own share of surprises and
opportunities of course the year 2020 is
a great example of this whatever plan
people may have laid in january has
almost certainly been disrupted by the
pandemic
and so i'm a huge believer in staying
adaptive staying flexible
and being opportunistic as things arise
and you know for me
sort of my blessing and my curse is that
i have a lot of different interests
and so there are a lot of things i want
to do in this world that are somewhat
unrelated to each other
and so for me venture capital is an
interesting
path because it does actually involve a
lot of diversity there are a lot of
different types of businesses we we
invest in
a lot of different sorts of challenges
and that's satisfying
um by contrast you know when you start a
company requires
uh a lot of focus on just that company
for a very long period of time
and there are advantages to that i
actually think you can have the most
impact in the world by starting a
business
much more than a vc can but the
trade-off is you're really thinking
about that one
industry that one product area for
potentially 10 to 12
15 20 years of your life and so for me
my own zigging and zagging in life has
been an attempt to
satisfy a diverse set of interests
going back all the way to being 12 years
old and resetting that that great
and that great poem but then you know a
lot of the people that are that are
hopefully watching this are our young
entrepreneurs whether they're from
stanford anywhere any other college in
the us
from tel aviv and it's a it's scary
you know there it feels like a constant
race there's a lot of pressure
going on that you have to raise the most
amount of money and you have to
to hire quickly and you have to to scale
really quickly and
what i'd love to spend the last few
minutes is
talking a little bit about your
perspective on this fresh young
entrepreneurial experience
and what myself and my friends can take
away moving forward as we begin our
entrepreneurial journey at the end to
make an impact
and what are some key things that we
should be keeping in mind and some key
pieces of advice that you've accumulated
over the years
well i think the sense of pressure on
oneself
has pros and cons i mean the truth is it
is a very competitive
world if you want to be successful in
anything that you do it would seem to be
obvious when you look at other
successful people that hard work's
required and that a lot of people try to
be successful but can't and so
and especially in fields like
entrepreneurship and venture capital
um it requires a ton of work and a lot
of luck i think to achieve any modicum
of success so
it's rational to feel some stress about
that
at the same time of course you don't
want to let the stress and anxiety and
the fear
uh be debilitating and you know it's
useful i think to cultivate a
a spiritual practice or uh to codify a
set of personal values or to remember
the bigger picture about what matters in
life
uh with regards to relationships and
family and things like that
uh so as to not not be totally overtaken
by the stress involved with your one's
career ambitions um
i'd say with respect to sort of things
to keep in mind i think if you know
the best decisions that i've ever made
and the worst decisions i've ever made
have had to do with people and judgment
of
people and so probably the single best
meta skill to develop or one of the best
meta skills because
i can think of some others as i say this
such as how to learn
but the meta skill for this conversation
that comes to mind michael is
being really good at evaluating people
and understanding whether you want
someone
in your tribe whether you want someone
working at your company whether it's
somebody you want to work for
and just calibrating your sense of how
do people
present themselves what are the sort of
things i'm looking for
when is someone trying to deceive me
when does someone deceive being
themselves
and they lack self-awareness about their
strengths and weaknesses etc people are
enormously complicated
they're also fascinating to get really
good at
understanding the psychology of people
is a generalizable skill that i think
will be helpful in any number of
career paths right 100 one of the things
that i i've gotten exposed myself over
the past year and a half or so
impala has been how how many
opportunities
there are and you know people that are
that are curious about
especially engineering and and you're
investing primarily and
in software and in it solutions i mean
the number of opportunities are just
endless and the ways in which we can
really improve the world is just
phenomenal
and for me as young entrepreneur what i
get most excited about is just thinking
of the
of all the different things we can do
that make it they can make a huge huge
impact which is why i
i i just love the the way that you're
talking about the zigzagging this
lifelong entrepreneurial journey it's
not just about this
what you're working on now it's about
how you're approaching every problem
with a potential solution and motivating
others along the way
and because i'm sure that just by having
that mindset yourself every person that
comes
that interacts with with ben gets get
that motivation as well so so thank you
for
being inspiration for me and for whoever
else is watching this before we go i
really want to thank you for being
generous with your time
and the hardest question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
three words that come to mind uh the
first obvious entrepreneurial
uh the second uh curious i have a lot of
different interests i'm curious about
things and the third would be
reflective i tend to reflect a lot on my
life and the world around me and uh
for better or for worse uh reflective
would be my third choice
it's very counter-intuitive to see
someone who's so german who's done so
much and then say that they're
one of the words that describes them as
reflective
which often has a connotation of sitting
back taking a moment breathing and
thinking
through what they're feeling so i i
highly appreciate that
then thank you very much and stay safe
and stealthy during these crazy times
and
i hope to meet in person back in the
silicon valley
thank you michael thanks for having me